[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Using the simulation tools available in Cisco Packet Tracer,
we're going to set up some basic scenarios where
connected devices can form a useful system
in the style of the Internet of Things.
So starting by adding a few devices to our workspace.
Looking at end devices, across here, we'll have a smartphone.
And, going back to the network devices, if we'll take a wireless device
category and put a cell tower in place.
So this combination of a smartphone and the cell tower
can help a person control, or monitor, devices in other places.
So these two can just sit off to the side for the moment.
And then, let's simulate some end devices within a home.
We'll start by putting in an air conditioner, the front door
of the house, which is locked.
Red means locked, green unlocked.
Open and close the door by holding down Alt button and clicking.
We'll put in the coffee maker and, for all this to connect,
go back to Network Devices, Wireless Devices.
Let's go with the standard home gateway.
This allows the house to connect to the internet,
acting as a wireless access point and a router,
so that we have the link between here and the person with their smartphone
via our cell tower.
So you can see the uses, in this case, as someone is getting closer to home.
The smartphone can either be set to automatically detect their location,
unlock the door, switch the air conditioner on, switch
the coffeemaker on, or it can be manually set to this using apps
within the smartphone.